[Music]
we just need 15 days
to slow the spread okay we slowed the
spread we
just need to flatten
the curve okay we flatten the curve we
just
hold just one more thing we just need to
find
a cure oh we found a cure okay well we
hey we come on man we just need
100 more days okay oh we're going to
give them 100 more days actually
indefinite lockdown what we're also
trying to do is make our health and
medical experts available to ensure
people understand and i'll reiterate it
here today
it's not just a vaccine as obviously an
incredible medical breakthrough
and we want every american to have one
but even after that vaccinated
uh social distancing wearing masks are
going to be essential and
we'll need to continue communicating
about that through health and medical
experts
you thought we were going back to normal
you believe that 15 days
slow the spread flattened that you
believe that you sucker
it was all a big lie i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from justin
crotter
who says quoting joe biden here
i'm not creating new laws i'm fixing bad
policies
he says i'm not stealing i'm
reallocating misused funds yes that's
very true
it's amazing how synonyms can sound so
very different
when you put them through political
correctness they all sort sort of change
but the meaning
remains exactly the same
and political correctness obviously
being pushed not just by these
politicians but by
everybody by the schools by the media
by big tech in particular that's why you
got to check out expressvpn
you do not need to give big tech
websites access to your data
why would you why would you want because
you love the big tech website so much i
don't think so
i strongly recommend you check out
expressvpn when you use expressvpn you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your ip address
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers what's
more
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your data to
protect you from eavesdroppers on your
network
and the expressvpn app could not be
easier to use
you just tap one button on your phone or
your computer you are
protected if you are listening to this
show there's
good chance that you check out some
pretty unsavory things on the internet
you open up that
incognito window maybe you close the
blinds
you go to dailywire.com i don't know i'm
just spitballing here
make sure you protect your online
privacy with the vpn
that i strongly recommend e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com
michael by visiting my link you will get
an extra three months of expressvpn
service for free
on a one-year package that is
expessvpn.com
michael expressvpn.com michael
to protect your data today you do not
want people who don't like you
seeing all of your data go get express
vpn i feel like this has been a very
gensake heavy week
i think that's because joe biden unlike
donald trump is not really talking to
the press
remember trump would have these
impromptu press conferences he'd be
walking to his motorcade he'd be walking
to
a helicopter and he'd just stand there
and just start chatting with the press
joe biden
is not doing that because joe biden
can't do that and so he sends poor jen
saki out
to have to answer these questions and
push his administration's policies
now a lot of the time as we've mentioned
on this show
saki seems unprepared she just doesn't
have answers for the things that she
should have answers for that's why she's
got to
circle back but sometimes
her poor performance is not because she
doesn't know what she's doing it's
because she
she can't give the the real answer
because if she gives the real answer it
will not be particularly palatable
to the american people good example of
this is on the cdc
the cdc has said reopen the schools
right
jen saki is asked a question by the
press she gets one real press question a
day all the rest are
how come joe biden is so handsome and
beautiful but she gets one or two real
real press questions one of which is hey
the cdc says we can reopen why aren't we
reopening the schools
here is her non-answer
i saw the comments of dr wolenski
but i will say that even she would say
if she were standing here she's welcome
to come anytime but she's in atlanta
that they have not released their
official guidance yet from the cdc on
the vaccination of teachers and what
would be needed to
ensure the safe reopening of schools and
so we'd certainly
defer to that which we hope to see soon
the president himself has talked about
the importance and the priority of
vaccinating teachers and in most states
they're in the 1b
category of vaccination and but
it is up to states to determine uh
prioritization obviously there's federal
guidelines but
and we work closely with governors but
we leave it to them but certainly
ensuring teachers are vaccinated
prioritizing teachers uh
is a is important to the president okay
i i don't know if you followed all that
gobbledygook that was meandering and all
over the place
but the gist of it was and remember joe
biden's administration they're going to
follow the science they're going to put
science first a lot of executive orders
to this effect
the gist of that was we need to
vaccinate teachers
and the states are going to run things
but the federal government has a role
and we need to vaccinate teachers
that is very important for when we
reopen
and since joe biden's administration is
following the science that's got to be
what the science says right because the
cdc they haven't issued any sort of
guidance yet
do you think that's right cdc director i
want to be very clear about
schools which is yes asip has put
teachers in the 1b
category the category of essential
workers
but i also want to be clear that there
is increasing
data to suggest that schools can safely
reopen
and that that safe reopening does not
suggest that teachers need to be
vaccinated in order to reopen safely
the teachers do not need to be
vaccinated to reopen safely the schools
can reopen
that's what the data show and joe biden
who says that data and science are going
to guide his administration would appear
to be denying
the science here and poor gensake has
got to go out there
and sputter in front of the press
because
she knows she's in this tight position
they've backed themselves into a corner
where they say we're going to let the
technocrats and the lab coats run our
entire government
the press says okay the lab coats say
that you get to reopen the schools
but joe biden is beholden to the teacher
unions right teacher unions
the unions generally are important to
biden uh and and trump did a lot to chip
away at democrats union support
but surely the teacher unions are a very
important one so joe biden forgetting
forgetting about the science for a
moment prioritizing
the political demands of these teacher
unions this would not be an example of
jen saki being bad at her job that's
actually an example of her being good at
her job but it shows the tough position
that the biden administration
has put her in speaking of lies and a
compliant press
they've outdone themselves they have
absolutely the press
and big technology and the democratic
establishment have outdone themselves
on lies in the past day and actually the
daily wire has played a role in this
so actually i guess this show sort of
played a role in this because we
we talked about yesterday how after aoc
recalls the harrowing
experience of how she was almost
murdered during the capital riot and how
cruz was going to murder her and she was
she it was having ptsd and trauma turns
out she wasn't even in the capitol
building
during the riot so the daily wire tweets
out this headline quote
this was a headline on our website
report
aoc was not inside capitol building
during breach on january 6.
snopes a fact-checking
website just a left-wing opinion website
but they call it a fact checking website
snopes rated this headline
mostly false now when snopes rates
headlines
they'll say maybe it's true or it's
false or it's mostly true it's mostly
false they will say here's what's true
and here's what's false so the original
headline was
report aoc was not inside capitol
building during breach on january 6th
snopes here's what's true
wait for it ocasio-cortez wasn't in the
main capitol building where the house
and senate chambers are located
okay what that sounds like that was just
the whole headline
aoc was not inside the capitol building
during the breach what's true
aoc wasn't in the main capitol building
where the where the house and senate are
okay what's false when the attack on the
capital began
ocasio-cortez was in her congressional
office which is located in a network of
office buildings
immediately surrounding the capitol and
her office building was
one of the two buildings that were
evacuated our headline didn't say
anything about that our headline didn't
mention that our tweet didn't mention
that
what we said was aoc was not in the
capitol building
then what they admitted was true is aoc
was not in the capital building
but then what they said was false was
that we we didn't mention that aoc was
in an office building down the street
well yeah she could have been in any
building down any street
she just wasn't in the main building
that this was we were all talking about
i don't know i guess there's no way
really to appeal this sort of thing and
what do i care i don't i don't have any
respect for snopes nor do any
republicans that i know or any
conservatives
but the problem is that big technology
companies team up with companies like
snopes
to determine whether or not your social
media
accounts are going to be de-platformed
whether they're going to be suppressed
whether they're spreading fake news
whether they'll be suspended
i mean snopes is just outright lying
right they
absolutely should just delete the whole
article and fire whoever wrote it but
they're not going to do that because
they're not a fact-checking website
they're a left-wing activist group and
that's why the left-wing activists at
big tech companies
are teaming up with them because they
can provide the facade of fairness
but to say well we're just talking to
the independent fact checkers we're just
talking to the experts the lab coats
we're just following the science
but then of course when objective
reality runs up against
one's political convenience guess what's
going to win out
you you heard jan saki you heard the
biden administration forget about that
science when it runs up against
our politics snopes forget about
objective reality
when it runs up against our politics
you want to hear the kicker oh my gosh
we have heard now
for two months no voter fraud in 2020
no election questions if you dare
question the election you're an
insurrectionist
you're a traitor murderer rapist you
need to be de-platformed you need
to be kicked off of the air you need to
be kicked out of polite society
so there's a hotly contested
congressional race in new york right now
this is in new york's 22nd
uh it's a race between anthony brindsey
and claudia tenney who i actually happen
to know
from new york politics so claudia tenney
had to see it then brendacy wins it now
it looks like tenny's gonna win it again
because brenda see the democrat is just
behind
the democrats are alleging voter fraud
specifically they're alleging that the
voting machines
are throwing the election to the
republican and demanding
a recount these candidates are separated
by 122 ballots
and the democrats while they are saying
that
any questioning of voter integrity and
in particular any questions
of voting machines you're getting a
billion dollar lawsuits
over voting machine fraud claims well
while they're saying that those are
completely illegitimate and you
basically need to be banished to a
faraway island if you bring them up
they're making the same claims
themselves
because they always do this sort of
thing and it just reminds me
of these squishy republicans who
follow the democrats line here they say
oh no we have to agree with the
democrats we have to
we can't we can't bring up the question
of fraud that's wrong we can't do that
we got to play by the rules here
democrats don't believe that they're
they're making the same claims when it
suits their
purposes gotta yeah i got these guys a
number you know you got it you gotta
know
their number uh one important number
that it's good to know is the time and
if you want another time you gotta check
out vincero watches
coming off the heels of some brand new
product releases vincero watches is here
to tell you that the perfect time to get
that perfect gift is
right now be sure to check out their
valentine's day sale it is officially
active for all my listeners if you visit
vincerowatches.com knowles k w l
e s if you're looking to upgrade your
look or better yet upgrade the look of
that special someone that deserves a
well thought out gift
now is your chance to get it on sale you
know i
actually just ordered a new vincero
watch yesterday i got the
bellwether i think it is absolutely
fabulous unfortunately it hasn't come
yet but i'm very very excited to get it
it's a really really
chic classic traditional looking
timepiece
looks really really high quality i've
loved watches since i was eight years
old
and the vincero watches are first of all
they look phenomenal and the deal is too
good to pass up
get access to their valentine's day sale
right now go to v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com slash knowles and the
discount will be auto-applied at
checkout
do not pay full price on these beautiful
timepieces go to my link and check out
these
fabulous fabulous watches really really
elegant time pieces
there had been a move in in the last
five or ten years i really like
timepieces so i
i sort of follow watch trends there had
been a move toward like super duper
minimalist
stuff and uh it became too much now
i think the the movement is a little bit
more for some
more aesthetic charm again a little more
ornate a little more
beautiful vincero really does that very
very well
republicans just don't get it
they think that democrats are being on
the level when they are
opposing these claims of voter fraud
right when
when we're talking about voter fraud in
the 2020 election
some people are making these very very
extreme claims
some might say outlandish claims about
mass fraud in the machines and the cia's
involved and it's in
germany and it's who knows there's space
aliens involved right you
there are extreme claims but then there
are the claims that are right before our
very eyes
which are undeniable namely
democratic election officials in
pennsylvania broke the law they violated
the state constitution which clearly
prohibits widespread mail-in ballots
how about the election poll watchers who
were sent home
illegitimately republican watchers sent
home in philadelphia
how about those videos we saw of of
election officials putting cardboard in
the windows
so the people who were outside couldn't
see what was going on in the counts
how about the the water main break right
the pipe leaking that sent home the
election officials in certain counties
what
all these little things far more
tangible
you can point to them meanwhile
democrats are making more outlandish
claims about voter fraud just in new
york's 22nd
congressional race and there are two
kinds of republicans the republicans who
recognize that the democrats are being
cynical and they're being cheap and that
we should be skeptical
of their efforts to take away election
integrity measures
those are the good tough serious
conservative republicans
and then there are the squishes there
are the squishy republicans
and i'm afraid to say senator ben sasse
who has done some good things i like
i like actually many of the things he's
done but he falls into the latter
category he seems to
prefer to scold republicans than to
deal seriously with these things ben
sasse
just released a video because he's being
censured by the nebraska gop
he's being censured because they think
he's gone squishy because in many cases
he has gone squishy
on policy you know generally speaking
he's been pretty good
but when it comes to these tough
political fights
he's gone weak and the nebraska gop is
threatening to censure him again
ben sasse releases a defiant video
pushing back
against the censure guys i want to talk
to the state central committee
i've heard from many of you in the days
since the attack on the capitol
threatening another censure for what i
said about the president's lies after
the election
as a friend and fellow republican i want
to shoot straight
i'm not going to spend any time trying
to talk you out of another censure
i listen to nebraskans every day and
very few of them
are as angry about life as some of the
people on this committee
not all of you but a lot political
addicts
don't represent most nebraska
conservatives
when melissa and i first ran back in 14.
pause it there
was it this is the first sign
that something is a little off here
when melissa and i first ran
who who's melissa i don't know who
melissa is like google melissa ben says
melissa
melissa is his wife melissa did not run
for office
melissa is not elected to any seat this
is something i've heard a lot of
politicians do this
all right i've heard a lot of good
politicians do this too but it i it
always grates on me
because politicians if they want to be
kind of disingenuous they'll they'll
pretend that it's not just them running
for office
this isn't about me this is about us
this is about when my family and i ran
when we all
no i don't i don't know i don't know who
the family is i'm not voting for the
family
i'm voting for you you're there's a job
and
there's only one spot and you're the guy
who's running for it so already to me
this is not you know a total
totally worth writing the guy off but
already i'm hearing this kind of
slick disingenuous political language so
i'm already uh i don't know if i like
this
the other thing he says here is
look the people who are obsessed with
politics they don't represent most of
nebraska
sure fair enough i guess most people
right we elect our representatives so
that they can go be obsessed with
politics instead of us
but we want you to be obsessed with
politics your job is to be obsessed with
politics
when i hear something like that when i
hear a politician
making fun of people who are obsessed
with politics i think oh this guy
doesn't like political fights
this guy's not in it for the fight he
wants to be nice he wants to be liked
but when when push comes to shove on the
really really tough fights
this guy doesn't sound like he's very
interested he goes on
many of the same party officials who
applauded in 14
cussed me out in 16 when i refused to
vote for candidate trump
and again when i declined to serve on
his re-election committee in 19
and again when i didn't vote for him in
20.
now many of you are hacked off that i
condemned his lies
that led to a riot okay here we go
here we go did trump
lie i don't know let's debate that
question another day i don't we don't
have time to deal with that right did he
lie did he exaggerate
was he did he have some evidence of was
he confusing certain things was he
conflating
whatever whatever he said let's go let's
go with ben
says downright lie did it lead to a riot
did trump incite the riot well he said
be peaceful
don't don't be violent right he said
that before
during and after so to me this this
seems dishonest
and then we remember ben sasse was a
arden never trumper
so he's an elected republican but he
didn't vote for the republican nominee
in 2016 he didn't vote for the
republican nominee even in 2020.
now i'm really skeptical of the guy
because even people who were
questioning trump in 2016 they thought
maybe he was going to be like a liberal
democrat or something like that i kind
of get it i understand why
because he had been sort of a democrat
for a lot of his life
but by 2020 he got a vote for the guy he
was it he was an excellent excellent
president
you've got to vote for the guy in 2020
if you're a republican so now i'm really
skeptical
and then ben sasse sort of seals the
deal
personality cults aren't conservative
conspiracy theories
aren't conservative lying that an
election has been stolen
it's not conservative acting like
politics is a religion
it isn't conservative i still believe
every word from the campaign trail
what makes america great isn't power
politics
it's what happens in the communities
where you and i are raising our kids
what makes america great isn't power
politics
but what makes politicians great is
being willing to exercise
power what are you talking about
of course yeah of course this guy
doesn't like power politics
he's explained it when push came to
shove when it was a little bit of a
tough election he didn't want to vote
for the republican nominee
even after the guy proved himself to be
a good republican president didn't want
to vote for the guy
he keeps coming back to this this motif
i don't i don't like politics
i don't want to play politics i don't
want to get into tough power politics
well the opposite of power politics is
weak politics impotent politics
it's too bad i i think ben sasse holds
many views
that are pretty conservative that i
would agree with i like that he's
highly educated i like that
but he keeps openly saying
he doesn't want the fight he doesn't
want to be involved in the nitty-gritty
fights he doesn't like it
he doesn't think that's what makes
america great democrats don't act like
that
you ever notice that democrats when they
have some kooky congressmen and by the
way they have
the kookiest congressman ever in the
history of this country
many of whom are serving right now they
don't wring their hands and
gnash their teeth and and rend their
garments and wail they don't
they don't say hem and ho oh gosh what
do we do we can't we have to
cast the spirit they just they just kind
of ignore it and actually in some cases
they promote these people to high
positions
and they don't complain and say i hate
power politics i hate
oh i hate the fighting and everything no
you know what they do they wield
political power and it's extraordinarily
effective
and it's actually responsible of them to
do that
because that's what their constituents
elected them to do
it's it's good to hold all the right
opinions i'm gl
and ben sasse largely holds the right
opinions
but he appears unwilling to do the other
part of the job
frankly maybe the more important part of
the job which is
exercise the power that you are given
he won't do that one thing that people
loved about trump
is they might disagree with him on this
they might disagree with him on that
they might not even like the way he
talks
but the guy was willing to wield power
he was often prevented from doing that
especially after
he lost the the house
and even a lot of people in the
republican establishment would would
hamper his plans
but he was willing to do things he was
willing to follow up on his campaign
promises
more so than any president of either
party in my lifetime
but certainly more so than any
republican president in my lifetime
and he was he was not afraid to exercise
power he was not afraid of being called
all sorts of names by democrats
really weak stuff i don't i mean i don't
care what the nebraska gop does if
they're going to censure him or not
i i don't think that we should cast ben
sasse even into the outer darkness but i
think the guy's got to come around
and get tougher and and be willing to
exercise power because
that's half the job and that's actually
the important half of the job
i'm man i'm really fired up i feel like
i've just got my blood flowing
testosterone pumping i think i'm going
to sprout a beard right here on set
that's how fired up i am and if i do
i'm certainly going to check out beard
supply it's february
and besides groundhog day valentine's
day and the occasional
29th day every four years it's a pretty
short month with not a lot to write home
about
except of course if you're familiar with
february
that's right febu harry do i say
februhary or feb you harry i don't know
it's very difficult to pronounce even
that month but it is the time of year to
get hairy
so please do yourself and all of us a
favor and do it in style
beard supply is running a promo right
now on all their beard oils
buy one get a second one for 50 off no
promo code necessary
just head on over to beardsupply.com to
get the discount today
beard oil not only moisturizes away the
itch it also nourishes your hair
for a better looking beard overall so
grab one today
and get a second one for 50 off knowing
that these oils are all natural and
all awesome for your whiskers whether
those whiskers be old
or new visit beardsupply.com to get the
promo code today that is beardsupply.com
and this month what is it called
why it's called february
go check them out today i i'll need to
just if i want to groom it properly you
know it's
these things don't just happen you gotta
you gotta take a little bit of care
go check out beard supply
you know we were talking about president
trump
and uh questions of voter fraud
and tough political fights like we're
going to get into with this impeachment
trial
which is not a real impeachment trial
it's a fake impeachment trial because it
doesn't satisfy
the constitutional requirements for
impeachment trials
namely donald trump is not the president
so not an impeachment trial per the
constitution
and he can't be removed from office
because he's not in office
and the chief justice is not presiding
as the constitution says
he must so there's some kind of trial
going on in the senate
this is uh really kicking off this week
so
all the preparation is going the briefs
have been filed this week and then we're
going to move into next week
the house impeachment managers want
president trump to testify and the big
question
for republicans and conservatives is is
trump going to play it safe
and are his lawyers just going to focus
on how this is an illegitimate
trial and doesn't meet the
constitutional standard and
you're going to have to acquit him or is
the guy going to go for broke
and is he going to present all the
evidence he's got of all the
irregularities and all the shady deals
that happened in
philadelphia and georgia wherever is he
is he going to make the case
that is now so politically incorrect
that there were lots of irregularities
in the election
and i don't know i'm of two minds on
this one it's probably safer
you know get acquitted in the trial make
sure there's no question that you could
run again if you wanted to run again and
uh moreover have this kind of fun
historical
you know fact which is he's the only
president to be impeached twice and he
got acquitted twice
uh or is he trump you know does he put
on the greatest show on earth does he
make this a spectacular a total blowout
go out not with a whimper but with a
bang seems like we're getting an answer
on this
trump was invited to testify by the
house impeachment managers
and his lawyers have turned it down
they've called this a public relations
stunt
uh they're not going to do it they they
don't want trump to testify so
if trump is not going to testify it
seems to me they're not going to make
this a big show
you'll remember my podcast with senator
cruz verdict
began during the last impeachment which
was just one year ago
and so we'll be covering this pseudo
impeachment trial again but it doesn't
appear that it's going to be a big deal
whatever is going on behind the scenes
trump is signaling he's not going to
make big claims
they'll let this thing fizzle and then
who knows maybe he'll come back
and run again now this doesn't mean that
trump has lost his gumption this doesn't
mean that trump has lost his fire
and his fight his vim and vigor
turning from politics back to trump's
other career in show business
president trump is a member of the
screen actors guild
uh he's the second president to be a
member of the screen actors guild ronald
reagan was the president of the
screen actors guild as you'll recall a
screen actor's guild
emerged with another show business union
called aftra some years ago probably
eight or nine years ago so now it's
sag-aftra
and it's a not a great union it's
it's actually a really terrible union
back in my truly wayward
irresponsible days i was for just about
three years a professional actor
and worked these union contracts under
sag-aftra
and the the union does nothing for its
members i mean it's really bad and i
a lot of friends of mine have been in
they've been in sag leadership
right they've they've helped run the
union or a lot a lot of friends of mine
have been in the union
and it doesn't matter their politics
obviously 99
of my friends who are in in the screen
actors guild are
left-wingers they hate the union too
this is a kind of
ubiquitous sentiment so
sag you know even though they don't do
anything for their members they want to
make all these big political stunts so
they say they're going to kick out
trump trump writes a letter to them
if you'll indulge me i want to read it
in large part if not in full
ms carterus i guess she's the head of
the union or something
i write to you today regarding the
so-called disciplinary committee hearing
aimed at revoking my union membership
who cares not a question mark
exclamation point
while i'm not familiar with your work
i'm very proud of my work
on movies such as home alone too
zoolander and wall street money never
sleeps
and television shows including the fresh
prince of bel air saturday night live
and of course
one of the most successful shows in
television history the apprentice
to name just a few exclamation point
i've
it's it just keeps getting better i've
also greatly helped the cable news
television business
said to be a dying platform with not
much time left until i got involved in
politics
and created thousands of jobs at
networks such as
msdnc and fake news cnn
among many others which brings me to
your blatant attempt at free media
attention to distract from your dismal
record as a union i'm gonna pause there
because trump always attacks
his opponents in these kinds of terms
you know low ratings no one likes you
but i mention all that stuff about sag
earlier to just tell you from
whatever sort of slight insidery
perspective i've got
truly the union members regardless of
politics
hate sag-aftra it is a bad union that
does not negotiate well for its members
your organization has done little for
its members and nothing for me besides
collecting dues and promoting dangerous
un-american policies and ideas
as evident by your massive unemployment
rates and lawsuits from celebrated
actors
who even recorded a video asking why
isn't the union fighting for me
these however are policy failures your
disciplinary failures are even more
egregious
i no longer wish to be associated with
your union
as such this letter is to inform you of
my immediate resignation from sag-aftra
you have done nothing for me
regards regards donald
j trump regards president donald j trump
now i read this not just because it's
absolutely hilarious
and it it makes me feel a little better
to know that trump still has his
typical fight in him and he's still
pushing back against these guys
but there's actually a bit of political
significance to this too
because we think of sag as just this
kind of show business thing
but it's a union right and unions
are the traditional domain of the
democrats we actually began the show
talking about this
right joe biden trying to play very safe
with the teachers union
he's willing to ignore the advice of his
cdc
follow the science joe biden is going to
ignore the scientific experts
just to keep the teacher unions happy
but what donald trump did was chip away
at the support for democrats among the
unions
he got these guys in all sorts of
different unions
to endorse him and so while
trump is you know blowing off steam and
he's yelling at this
union hack whatever corteris from sag
he's also sending a political message
and republicans would would do very well
to hear that political message
uh ted cruz so i'm about to go fly down
and see because we're doing an event for
young america's foundation we're gonna
do verdict live cruz has said
the republican party if it's gonna have
a future needs to be the party of
pittsburgh not the party of paris it's
gotta be the
party of working men and women not the
party that the democrats have kind of
caricatured us as
of oligarchs and you know billionaires
and rich uncle pennybags
trump is signaling in in this letter
he's doing it in a hilarious way but
he's signaling in this letter
that is the future of the democratic
party these unions
these elites have lied to the
constituents that they take for granted
you should vote for us what have you got
to lose give us a chance
don't get fooled again you know
ben is going to be digging into the the
biden administration undercutting the
cdc director
he's going to be uh he's going to be
analyzing the science
as we like to say and also the
biden administration's executive actions
proposed executive actions to forgive
student loan debt so go take a listen to
that and
also you can get 25 off
a new daily wire membership with code
rhf
for just a very little while longer not
much longer sign up today
watch our first feature film run hide
fight run hide fight
was our launch into the entertainment
world just a few weeks ago the critics
hate it because the movie is not
politically correct
it's not it's not super conservative
right it's not like a propaganda movie
but it's just not
it doesn't check the woke boxes so
critics hate it
and uh the audience loves it the
audience score is super high so
go check it out you can get 25 off using
code rhf
join the daily wire today this is your
last chance the the promo is only
available through the weekend
put in code rhf 25 off we'll be right
back with the mailbag
welcome back first mailbag question is
from
ben is there a balance between attaining
as much
virtue as one should before entering
into romantic relationships
versus dealing with scruples how do you
know when you are ready
to date if you are struggling with vices
okay excellent excellent question for
those who don't know
what scruples are or scrupulosity
it's uh kind of the opposite problem
that most people are facing right now
most people are facing this problem
where they
they refused to even acknowledge the
reality of sin and vice and they just
think we can do whatever we want
as long as we all consent we can do
whatever we want right we've been
talking about that this week on the show
uh the opposite problem though but
it's also a serious problem is when you
think that everything is a sin
even things that aren't sins and so
you're just so afraid and you you refuse
to do anything and you're kind of
you're hampered and frozen by fear of
sinning even on perfectly ordinary
things
and how this relates to dating uh it is
it is certainly the case that if you are
mired in vice and you're a total
degenerate and derelict
then you can really hurt people when
you're dating or
dating casually or maybe i'm even using
the word dating too broadly
but when you're you know chatting up the
ladies yeah you can do that and that's
something you should keep in check and
just don't be a jerk you know and just
every time you are tempted to be a jerk
which will be frequent
uh don't be and when you do behave like
a jerk feel bad about it
and maybe go to confession this is my
sort of catholic advice on it
but just try not to do it again but
don't don't live your life in fear
goodness gracious man i mean the the
process of adolescence and beginning to
date
and you know chatting up different girls
is it coincides with a period in which
you're going to be learning a lot of
things
it that process itself will educate you
as well
so i would say go out there chat up the
chicks and and don't be
a jerk but but do
do not be do not be hampered by fear you
if you wait until you attain perfect
virtue
to go date girls you're you're probably
going to be sitting at home a lot
and if something tells me that one of
the vices you're alluding to
is internet porn because every
every guy basically who writes into the
show with questions like this
refers to internet porn at some point or
is alluding to internet porn because
it's
it's a ubiquitous vice and temptation it
relates directly
to relationships and to romance and to
marriage uh
over 90 percent of guys well over 90 of
guys
have looked at it at some point many of
many many of those people look at it
very young i think
the average or median age at which point
young boys are exposed to this is like
11 or something
so yeah it's a big problem and it can it
can mess you up but uh
you you know you the only way out is
through right you're not going to get
everything about your life in order
personally privately in your own head
and then you're going to be able to go
out and and
interact in society it ain't going to
happen so you gotta you gotta just
work on all of these things at once you
can't freeze time
we've been we've been talking about this
a little bit on the show too you know
we're living in time so you've gotta
you've gotta be able to do multiple
things
at once work on yourself and go out and
build your life
and build your career and build your
hobbies and
you can't just only do one of those at a
time from nick
hey michael long time listener first
time mailbag question the groundhog saw
his shadow
should we ask dr fauci if that means six
more years to slow the spread
uh yeah i think we absolutely should the
problem is we won't be able to trust
whatever answer he gives us
because he could come out and say well
the groundhog
is very clear and i've been very clear
from the beginning
the groundhog is six more years to slow
the spread
and then six years later we're gonna say
okay we're good now we can we can all
i never said that the science is very
very clear
you've all got to wear the masks and put
the donut on your head
and jump up and down on the pogo stick
for another 25
years that's the science that's what's
very very important
next question from bryson hey michael
congrats on the baby thank you very much
my pastor recently preached a sermon
online
where he said that we should file this
is why it was online
because he said we should follow
government lockdown rules because of
romans
13 verse 1 everyone must submit himself
to the governing authorities
for there is no authority except that
which god has established
what is your response when christians
use this verse to say that we must
follow the insane china virus
restrictions p.s i love your show
thank you for all that you do at the
daily wire
do you or does your pastor read that
line
from romans to mean that the
earliest christians should have
worshipped pagan idols right
christianity spread
in many ways through the blood of the
martyrs
and there were many many christian
martyrs during the roman empire
who refused to worship the roman pagan
gods
and worship pagan idols
it was the law but they broke the law
and
they suffered the consequences for
breaking the law and then they went up
to heaven because they were martyrs
does your pastor really believe that
romans is uh
saying that we shouldn't do this i don't
i can't imagine he thinks that
uh you know one thing i would recommend
on this point because
we we do have to give great deference to
civil authority and the civil authority
is there for our own good and the the
state is not an illegitimate thing and
it is
it is there for our own good and you
know hierarchies of rule
exist for our own good and and uh exist
all the way up to the kingdom of heaven
sure
uh however saint thomas aquinas
recognizes there that there are times to
overthrow a tyrant's shackles
and so the question is what is that time
and how should we do it one
recommendation i would give you is to go
take a listen to spencer clavin's young
heretics podcast
he just did the last couple of days he's
done a series on
the right of revolution and the right of
civil disobedience and the right to push
back against these things that would be
some great
extra listening i'll give you a short
answer here in case you don't want to
take the time to listen to spencer's
show
which is we are now told
that we need to pay obeisance
to many rituals of the liberal
liturgical calendar
right we are told it is right and just
to go out and
perform the blm rituals which mostly
involve burning down cities and stealing
gucci handbags
we're told it's perfectly fine to
observe the antifa rituals
but we can't go to church churches are
closed
the big left-wing events are open which
have a liturgical and religious
character those are those are open
the uh marijuana dispensaries in
california they've been open pretty much
the whole time they're essential but
churches are
closed it would seem to me obviously not
a perfect analogy
a very very very diminished version but
there are still
some similarities to any any government
that would force you to participate in
in one religion and disregard your own
religion and i
can say this especially for catholics
catholics
can't stream the mass forever we
we have an incarnational faith right
and many protestant denominations
particularly the older protestant
denominations
have this recognize this kind of
incarnational aspect
we need to go there we need to do it we
can't be cut off from the sacraments
forever
and if the civil authority is going to
cut you off from the sacraments forever
then you've got to disobey that
authority
from rebecca i'm having a hard time
meeting someone i want to date who is
catholic oh catholic question but i've
met a lot of great protestants is it
okay to date and marry a protestant as a
practicing catholic
i'm worried about secretly always hoping
they'll change as i know i'd pray for
their
conversion i expected you to advise
against this until i heard that when you
married your wife she was a protestant
she was not a protestant but she was not
a catholic
uh what was your thought process well
yeah i'll give you i mean since you
bring up the example of my wife i can
i'll bring up my own example
from for most of the time i guess maybe
not most of the time but
for the early time that my wife and i
dated did you remember we were high
school sweethearts and split for college
uh we were both
practically atheists and we didn't have
any religion we didn't practice
any religion other than you know the
religion of secular liberalism
and then i you know had this kind of
reversion
on the road to damascus i had this kind
of
coming back to the church and then that
of course spurred all of these
conversations with my wife
and uh you know her own thinking about
this matter so i i always say
you know you either grow together or you
grow apart
and that that will be an aspect of this
from a very practical perspective
though uh you should know that if you
want to be married
as you are a catholic if you want to
marry a protestant you need to marry him
and and you want to remain catholic you
need to marry him in the catholic church
you need to get a dispensation from your
bishop and you need to agree to raise
the children catholic
now if your potential husband would
would agree with this
then he will be practicing a different
religion
than his entire family but he also has
to be the head of the household he also
has to lead his family so it would seem
much easier for him to just become
catholic um or
he could leave he could defer to you as
in spiritual matters but he still would
you know have to go to mass right i
don't see any world in which you could
raise a catholic family but daddy
doesn't go to mass
so he'd have to go to mass and he'd have
to basically give all the kind of
spiritual leadership
to you and maybe you are okay with that
maybe he's okay with that
maybe you're not i have seen this work
where you know good big old catholic
family where the
the husband does not convert but he
basically just goes along with
everything and doesn't have really
strong
religious views himself you could do
that i think that's probably the
exception rather than the rule
probably better to confront this issue
and grow together rather than grow apart
because if you grow apart after the
marriage after the wedding that's that's
going to be a very bad situation
from sarah hey michael love the show
what authority are you speaking under
when you criticize the pope well there's
a very catholic heavy mailbag
what authority are you speaking under
when you criticize the pope and the
vatican
oh i'm gonna pause there one second i
don't know that i have criticized
the pope and the vatican i've raised
many questions about things that the
pope has said
and i've raised many doubts about
things that the vatican has done but i
and
so in that way i guess it's critical um
but i haven't you know
there's no video on the internet of like
michael knowles destroys
his the holy father with facts and logic
i don't i don't do that
uh shouldn't all catholics be looking to
the same authority are there specific
sections of the catechism being violated
so i guess if your question is how dare
a
catholic criticize the pope i i would
encourage you to read dante
who puts two popes in hell you know
being being sort of tormented for
eternity there's a long tradition
of of the catholic laity and of
priests and even sort of lower lower
tier members of the episcopacy
raising questions and doubts about
things that the pope has said and done
there are
filial questions that we can ask them
fraternal corrections we can make of our
fellow catholics
uh cardinal burke famously in in this
pontificate has raised
dubia a series of doubts to
to the pope that he wants the pope to
clarify because certain things the pope
have said has said
seem uh very very questionable if not
outright heretical and the pope has
refused to
to acknowledge those dubia from from his
eminence cardinal burke
uh so perfectly in keeping with catholic
tradition to raise these sorts of
questions
i'm not suggesting that you know we
ought to have a revolution
you know and overthrow the pope or uh
you know have a recall election or
something i don't i don't believe any of
that
stuff but likewise i think we're really
perverting the
catholic view of things when we say that
nobody can question the pope some of the
some of the greatest writings in the
history of the church come from vigorous
questions and even some some criticism
of of
the episcopacy and even the pope from
tyler
dear michael knowles i noticed that you
have talked about how mccarthyism is
twisted in our history books i was
wondering if you could share what
sources show what really happened
well you know a great a great book on
this is by william f buckley jr
who is credited with founding the modern
conservative movement
uh bill buckley wrote his first book god
and man at yale but his second book was
called mccarthy and his enemies in that
book he said
and i'm paraphrasing but only lightly
that mccarthyism
is a political movement around which men
of good will
all men and women of goodwill can
can surround around which they can
surround i don't know i'm messing up the
words a little bit but
uh you know a movement that they all can
embrace what did mccarthy do mccarthy
said there are communists working in the
government high-profile communists in
high-profile positions
and we need to root them out because
there are subversives who are working in
some cases explicitly
at the behest of an enemy state that was
true that was 100 true
it was proven true in the alger his
trial um
many other cases as well you saw
prosecutions under the smith act during
the
the 1950s of communists subverting the
the country
but alger hiss was a high-ranking
official he helped found the united
nations
and he was an active underground
communist
another great book detailing that case
was witnessed by whitaker chambers so
mccarthy was right
he was twisted he's been certainly
defamed by history he's
he's a flawed guy in many flaws maybe he
hurt the cause more than he helped it
some people make that argument but to
say the cause was unjust is absolutely
preposterous the left has never forgiven
him for being right about what they were
doing
just like they never forgave richard
nixon for being right about alger hiss
actually because nixon was one of the
people who brought hiss down
the real history much more interesting
than the revision that we
that we get the bubble gum history that
we get from propagandists on the left
all right that's our show
check us out in miami i'm heading down
there now we will have a yaf
freedom conference verdict live in the
meantime i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
see you next time
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire hey everybody this
is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin